dijo precisamente que esta información
que a vida recogido el FBI no había sido
corroborada no había sido analizada
concretamente y que podía tener vicios
partidistas también resaltó que estos
estándares de investigación que usó en
su momento el FBI y la Cia no fueron los
mismos para
la campaña de hillary Clinton y su
posible su supuesta interferencia en la
en las presidenciales de el 2016 el
fiscal especial no acusó O no recomendó
cargos en contra de ningún individuo a
pesar de haberse demorado casi cuatro
años en esta investigación que el
reporte entregó casi 300 páginas ese
reporte ya había sido entregado el
viernes al fiscal general de Estados
Unidos
y hoy fue entregado al congreso
y Cristóbal se ha pronunciado trampa al
respecto Y cómo puede influir esto en su
carrera Para volver a la Casa Blanca
pues es sin duda son buenas noticias
para la campaña de Donald Trump le dan
una justificación para seguir con el
argumento de que él es víctima de una
cacería por parte de el gobierno
profundo acá en Washington que quiere
destrozar su campaña y sus chances de
volver a la Casa Blanca en el 2024 en su
red social dijo que este reporte era una
evidencia de que el estado había
engañado al pueblo estadounidense como
lo sigue haciendo en este momento por su
parte Jim Jordan que es congresista
republicano le dijo a su comité al
comité de judicial que preside además
que ya habló con el
secretario de de Justicia para que
vaya a testificar la próxima semana en
el comité de Justicia del congreso para
que los estadounidenses conozcan más
detalles sobre este reporte